BRADY HARAN: Hi everyone.
You've probably noticed from
the lack of "Numberphile"
videos lately and my
Grizzly Adams beard
that I've been away.
I've been in Nepal doing various
bits and pieces.
But I've also been keeping my
eye open for bits of numbery
trivia and a few things I've
come back with that I thought
were worth sharing.
Now, anyone who knows anything
about Nepal knows almost
everywhere you go, you're
being watched by these
Buddhist wisdom eyes.
But one thing I didn't know
was that little curly nose
that looks like a question
mark, well
actually, that's a number.
It's an ornate version of
the Nepali number one.
Its symbolism is unity.
And here's the number
one on their money.
You can see that's what
a one looks like.
And here's the number one on
a motorcycle license plate.
So there are always numbers
where you least expect it.
Another number that's really
important in both Buddhism and
Hinduism, I learned, was 108.
And 108 is everywhere
in Nepal.
Even these recesses here
cut in the stupa,
there's 108 of them.
It's actually quite good fun
when you're in Nepal seeing
how many places you can
find that number 108.
Now, here's another
number, 261.
That's the number of photos
on this SD card.
This card was found by my
Nepalese trek leader, Budhi,
while he was actually going to
the toilet in some bushes.
It was raining.
And this thing was soaking
wet when he found it.
But we found out later on, the
photos were still on there.
I don't know whose
photos they are.
But I know if someone found my
holiday photos, I'd want them
to return them.
So if you recognize these
people, have a look at the
link under my video and help
me get in touch with them,
because I'd love to return their
holiday photos to them.
Now, that trek was to
Everest base camp.
And those of you who are
familiar with "Numberphile"
will know that I actually
went there last year.
It's a place I'm really into.
Have a look at this photo I
took this year, though.
There's Mt.
Everest in the background.
8,848 meters high.
We're having a bit of fun
there with the torch.
I've already done a video
about the height of Mt.
Everest and some
of the numbers.
So have a look at that if it's
something that interests you.
And another video we've done
before is all about the
Nepalese flag.
So that's one you can also
have a look at if you're
interested.
But this year what I did, was
as we went to all the
different elevations, we boiled
water and had a look at
how the boiling point
of water changes.
BUDHI: And the boiled water
temperature is 88.
BRADY HARAN: I'm doing that
video for my chemistry
channel, which is called
"Periodic Videos." So
subscribe to that and have a
look if it's something you
might be interested in.
It's very numbery, of course.
And just to show that I'm
always thinking of
"Numberphile," I couldn't
resist getting a bit of
footage of this mountain here.
It's called Mt.
Numbur.
That's Numbur, Numbur.
I read on the internet that
some people say it has the
shape of a female breast.
It's not something
I can see myself.
But there you go, Mt.
Numbur for all the
numberphiles.
E making be equal to ab.
4 touching e, draw a line fg
starting from the point f on
line ac, parallel
to ab to the--